he told me my career is over kim
kardashian claims her estranged husband
kanye west had some harsh words for her
following their split it is what it is
the 41 year old skims founder filed for
divorce from the grammy winner back in
february 2021
and in a new episode of hulu's the
kardashians kim opens up about the not
so nice things kanye allegedly said to
her amid their breakup he told me my
career is over and then he showed me a
picture of marge simpson wearing
something
the kkw beauty founder is referring to
this outfit she rocked while being
honored at the wall street journal
magazine innovator awards in october and
marge simpson well yeah it's exactly who
you're thinking the simpsons family
matriarch well it doesn't matter how you
feel inside you know
it's what shows up on the surface that
counts that's what my mother taught me
at the time the reality star publicly
praised the 44 year old musician for his
impact on her fashion telling the outlet
quote kanye will always be the most
inspirational person to me i always know
his heart
but now kim says she's trying to venture
out on her own and find her own style
fashion has always been something that
i've always been really into but i've
never been like the creative i
definitely see
what i like but i've never really been
like the visionary i always just trusted
in him but
it's not just about clothes that was
like the last thing we had really in
common i was always like the kardashians
with my sisters and then i was like kim
yay like who is kim k
that is the jump how do i get there
without kanye kim filed for divorce
after six years of marriage and back in
december she requested to be declared
legally single and to restore her last
name a request that was granted in march
and kim notes that she was very sure
that her marriage was over when she made
the decision to walk away i knew it had
to be done when i filed because i just
knew it wasn't the right situation for
me and now i feel super good
now kim is dating saturday night live
star pete davidson
he's just super genuine
and it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing
[Laughter]
but kim says it's been hard to
experience the double standards as her
and kanye's split plays out in the
public eye
i'm always super protective of kanye and
not sharing a lot of the negative things
that have happened just because you know
he's not here doing the show also if i
do something on a reality show then it's
like how dare she talk about it and then
he can do a song and but that's so
creative and expressive and you know
it's always like two different sides are
being expressed two different ways and
one is respected and one's not but last
month a source told e.t kanye is trying
to disconnect from all the drama that
happened between them
as for kim and the 28 year old comedian
things seem to be getting serious yep
the two made their red carpet debut at
the white house correspondents dinner
earlier this month before hitting the
met gala together
and pete he has the kardashian family
seal of approval i love that he's
kind and really really thoughtful he's
the most thoughtful person
and i love
yeah and i love the chemistry that kim
and him have together it's really sweet
i thought you said the chemistry it's
like okay chemistry
chemistry
[Music]
you